>> Welcome back to an amazing
day two of Google Cloud Next.
Wasn't yesterday awesome?
[Applause]
Today we have a
really packed agenda, and we're
going to try and top yesterday
with great, great new
announcements in lots of product
areas. Yesterday we talked
about our vision as Google for
cloud computing, to give you
global scale distributed
infrastructure, a digital
transformation platform, and
industry specific solutions that
facilitate digital
transformation. Today we have a
packed show. Going to start off
talking about some new things
we're doing in infrastructure
and security, talk about data
management, smart analytics,
advances in AI and Machine
Learning, what we're doing in
collaboration, and industry
specific solutions. To kick off
today, let me welcome Urs Hölze,
senior Vice President technical
infrastructure. Urs?
[Applause]
>> Good morning! Every day,
Google Cloud connects to over a
billion IP addresses all over
the world, not for Google, but
for GCP customers. And those
bits travel on our network, and
99% of the time, they get handed
off directly to the last mile
ISP, so we can control security
and performance all the way.
Now, our scale has taught us
that we can always do better to
do more to help our customers
succeed. And that thought guides
us at Google when we think
about capital investments, when
we think about product
priorities. As Thomas and Sundar
underlined yesterday, we're
spending an enormous amount of
capital and human resources to
build out that vision: $13
billion just this year, just on
data centers, just in the U.S.
And of course, there's more. So
there might be better forms of
hardware for Machine Learning.
There might be advanced,
efficient data centers, better
data storage, smarter analytics.
So we're committed to bring a
lot more cloud to you, not just
in our data centers, but also in
your data centers. We believe
in a cloud with a lot less
hassle. The cloud is too hard
today, and it's our job to make
it simpler, through easier
policy management, through
consistent APIs, through open
source software that works where
you need it. And that's the
guiding principle between the
cloud services platform, which
we announced last July, to
manage containers and services
both on premise and on GCP.
And
just eight months later,
yesterday, we announced a final
product, Anthos, and simply put,
I believe that Anthos is the
future of Cloud. That's a big
statement. Why? Because Anthos
is a single platform that lets
you develop secure, release,
monitor, operate, debug your
services. It's mature. It's
robust. It has advanced
functionality, even today. So,
the stack, the Anthos stack,
includes container
orchestration, service
management, config and policy
management, dev ops tooling, and
a robust marketplace, as you
saw yesterday, so that customers
can have a unified experience
when they consume the products
and services of independent
software vendors. And it works
equally well for your existing
as well as new software so you
don't have to rewrite to get the
benefits. And of course, it
works wherever your teams are
working. And last but not least,
since it's fully managed, even
on premise, you don't have to
worry about operating and
updating the platform, so you
get a Cloud experience in your
data center as well. If you want
to know more, I invite you to
join the ask me anything session
tomorrow morning at 9:00. There
were also lots of sessions
yesterday that you can recap on
video.
Now, customers started
using the CSB beta several
months ago and now are starting
to use Anthos in production, and
the feedback has really been
excellent. They're working
faster with fewer impediments
and more freedom. And because
it's based on open source, it's a
safe choice for years to come.
It's not a single network
choice. So that's why I believe
that Anthos really is a great
choice for the cloud strategy of
any enterprise.
And with
Anthos, we're making hybrid and
multi cloud the new normal. You
see that in our new traffic
director, which seamlessly
balances your traffic across
both on premise and GCP
instances and soon, across
instances in other clouds as
well. It works for both VMs and
containers. It routes traffic
over our backbone so your
application gets unparalleled
resiliency of that network.
Or
take our approach to serverless
computing so functions, you
know, the ability to run code
without managing VMs or
containers. Cloud Run, a new
product that you will hear a lot
more in this afternoon's
developer keynote, combines the
speed and ease of use of
serverless computing of
functions with the flexibility
and portability of containers,
so you can use any language and
any runtime in Cloud Functions,
not just what your vendor
happens to provide. And of
course, it's based on open
source, Knative, and it will be
part of Anthos, so it will work
everywhere you want it to work.
Now, the cloud isn't just about
deploying and managing
applications. It's also about
data. And one of GCP's biggest
strengths is to help you do more
with your data. You can ingest,
integrate, analyze, predict
both with traditional analytics
and with Machine Learning. And
of course, we offer a cloud
platform with natural language
understanding that's built in
both into your apps and into our
apps. So that's a purposeful
AI. Like an assistant for your
call centers or for your
enterprise for a better customer
or employee experience. So we
make AI accessible not just as
technology and tools but also as
solutions.
And that's also
true for our collaborative
applications. You will hear more
later but using Gsuite, teams
communicate and deliver faster,
so you get better workforce
engagement and better
productivity/ There's always up
to date documents, for example,
with live commenting. There's
video conferencing that just
works. And there's AI to boost
your productivity in
spreadsheets, documents, and e
mail.
But now let me turn to
security because we know that no
company can serve its customers
without the greatest trust in
the reliability and security of
the platform that it's running
on. And at Google, security is
really something that we have
built in from the start
comprehensively. It's not
something that's bolted on
later. And as Thomas mentioned
yesterday a little bit, we start
with the principle that your
data is your data and only your
data. It's the lifeblood of your
company, and no one should
access it without your knowledge
and consent    not Google, not
vendors that you engage, not
employees that you don't want to
have access. And we're the only
cloud that offers access
transparency logs products
access transparency logs for
virtually all of our products
that document such
administrative access in near
realtime.
We also provide
powerful data security tools
like the data loss prevention to
discover and classify sensitive
data wherever it is. And we
have VPC service controls, it's
the new feature that allows you
to segment multi tenant
resources of cloud services to
mitigate data exfiltration
risks. So it allows you to
combine the benefits of and
strengths of such managed
storage without exfiltration
risks, and so it combines those
services with the security of a
private, truly private cloud.
And you can only get them on
Google Cloud.
In fact, you'll
see 30 more announcements at
just Next that are related to
security. So I can't mention
them all, but I will call out
just a few more. Cloud Security
Command Center provides a single
view of all of your assets,
buckets, containers, and their
risk profile. And Event Threat
Detection let's you    is a new
service we're introducing that
lets you spot signs of
compromise or malicious activity
in your logs. And last but not
least, policy intelligence is
something I'm very excited
about. It's a Machine Learning
based service that gives you the
confidence that you actually
specified the right set of
access controls and that you're
not accidentally giving overly
broad access to people.
Now,
while it's critical to secure
servers and services, we also
make it easy to secure your
users and end devices as part of
the end to end strategy. First,
Chromebooks are the most secure
and easy to manage enterprise
laptops on the market, period.
Because you have no OS patching
and no back ups to worry about.
Like we do all of that. And with
hardware verified goods in
every single laptop, they're
virtually immune to virus
attacks. We also developed
security keys, now an industry
stand, to help protect accounts
from phishing and to make strong
authentication as easy as
touching a security key. Because
e want as many users as
possible to take advantage of
that. Today we're announcing a
software security key that will
work in most Android phones. So,
soon, a billion users will be
able to take advantage of it and
secure their accounts like
never before.
So let me now
briefly show you how all of
these security features work
together for end to end
protection. So let's assume
you're taking an existing
application and you're moving it
into Anthos, on premise or in
the cloud, doesn't matter, it's
the same. So, you immediately
pick up all of the built in
security features of Anthos like
strong service identities and
encrypted communication between
services, centralized policy and
config management. You get that
out of the box. And then by
putting our identity or our
proxy in front of it, you now
get single sign on with security
key second factor for this
application. And you can
configure further context of
where access policies for that
application. And if you have
business customers, you can use
Apigee API management to expose
services to other businesses in a
B2B setup. All of that without
touching your application, your
existing application. And since
Anthos has centralized audit
logging, all of the logs can be
fed into BigQuery or event
threat detection to give you
critical insights about this set
up. So it's a simple,
consistent way to modernize not
just the application but
modernize your security posture
and move to a zero trust model.
Now all of this is built in
close coordination with our
customers and partners, as you
have seen a growing list of some
of the world's largest
Enterprises. And we're really
honored to have their trust.
Now, while there are many new
features that we're announcing
today, they're all part of a
larger, single consistent
vision: A cloud platform that's
uniquely built around open
standards with production grade
code. So you pick your
environment, on prem or in the
cloud, and you don't have to
change a thing. And you see that
commitment to up time and to
reliability in the Google Cloud
as well. In fact, recently, two
leading third party research
firms published their findings
about 2018 cloud reliability.
And I want to say this research
was neither sponsored, nor
influenced by Google. But GCP
demonstrated.
[Applause]
Thank you. GCP demonstrated by a
substantial margin the highest
reliability of the three major
clouds, right? It's not even
close. So, to wrap up, at Google
Cloud, we're investing a lot in
security and in your future.
You can see that really
throughout all of today's
announcements. And of course you
get great reliability and great
security on GCP, and you reduce
the complexity of your IT so
that you can move faster. So,
thank you for choosing us as a
partner for your journey to a
simpler, more secure, naturally
hybrid cloud. Thank you, and now
back to Thomas.
[Applause]
>> Thank you, Urs. In addition
to security, we at Google take
you as customers and your trust
in Google extremely seriously.
One of the issues we want to
address at the conference is the
issue of privacy and our stance
on it. It's very simply put:
Your data is your data and no
one else's. Your AI models are
your AI models and no one
else's. No one at Google will
access your data without your
permission. We do not have a
back door to allow any agency to
access your data without your
permission. You can encrypt the
data at rest or in transit into
our cloud. You can use your own
encryption keys to encrypt that
data. If you want Google to help
you access that data for a
support purpose, we will stream,
in near realtime, the logs of
every operation our people are
doing to help you with the
support request. No other cloud
provider provides you these
facilities. And for us, that's a
measure of providing you the
comfort and trust that Google
will never, ever use your data
for any other purpose outside of
delivering you the service in
GCP that you're using.
[Applause]
Now, one of the key
areas that people wanted us to
provide great technology for is
the area of data management. We
offer a number of solutions for
data management: To rehost
enterprise databases in our
cloud, to help you migrate
databases from on premise data
centers to our cloud, and great
new solutions to build new
scalable applications using the
broad portfolio of assets that
we as Google provide for data
management. Today we're going to
show you how to move Microsoft
SQL server, Windows, and active
directory to our cloud. There
are many other capabilities
we're introducing in data
management. To show you that
with a demonstration, please
welcome Deepti Srivastava from
product management. Deepti?
>> Thank you, Thomas. I'm
excited to be here today to talk
to you about databases, which
we know are a critical part of
your business. Google Cloud
offers a wide portfolio of
database services for
transactional, operational, and
analytical workloads, all
protected from threats by
advanced security. We know it
can be challenging to build new
applications and to bring
existing workloads to the cloud.
That's why we are committed to
providing a first class
experience to you as you move to
Google Cloud, including for
your Windows workloads.
So
let's take a look. Here we have a
typical Windows app,
Adventureworks. Just like many
Windows applications, this one
runs on a Virtual Machine and
uses SQL server as its database
back end. You might have
thousands of Windows
applications, from small simple
ones like this. To large,
critical applications running in
your data centers. To help lift
and shift windows workloads to
the cloud, Google Cloud provides
tuned Windows and SQL server
virtual machine images. You can
bring your existing licenses and
run them on sole tenant to stay
in compliance or buy licenses
through us.
Now let's turn our
attention to SQL server. Our
cloud SQL managed data service
offers support for MySQL and
Postgres. Today I'm excited to
announce that Cloud SQL will
offer fully managed Microsoft
SQL server later this year.
[Applause]
Thank you. It works
with all of your familiar tools
but better because it's fully
managed. This gives you and your
teams the opportunity to focus
on building what's next.
Now,
let's modernize this
Adventureworks app, starting
with the database. Using SQL
server management studio, we'll
take a full backup of the SQL
2008R2 database used by this
app, we'll simply run the
command in SMMS to generate the
file. Once completed, we can
upload this to our Google Cloud
storage bucket. We've already
uploaded the generated file to
the appropriate bucket, as you
can see in the console here.
Next, we'll restore the back up
to Cloud SQL for SQL server.
We'll select the managed
instance we have created, select
import, and select the doc BAK
type. From here, we will then
find and select the GSC bucket
where we have uploaded the file,
type in the database name, and
select import to initiate the
restore. Once the restore is
complete, all we have to do is
copy the IP address and just
change the connection string in
the configuration file for the
application. That's it! You can
refresh, and now our
Adventureworks app is up and
running on managed SQL server
for the latest version of SQL
server. [Applause]
Thanks.
So, to recap, Cloud SQL for SQL
server is a fully managed
database service that handles
the mundane tasks of operating a
database for you so you can
spend more time innovating. But
we know that SQL server isn't
the only critical part of the
Windows ecosystem. Active
directory is the standard for
authentication for authorization
in Windows environments. Today
you can run active directory
yourself on GCP and federate AD
users to GCP with cloud
identity, our identity
management service. But we
wanted to enhance this
experience for you. So, I'm
happy to announce that managed
service for Microsoft active
directory will be coming later
this year to GCP.
[Applause]
This new managed service runs
actual AD domain controllers and
makes it easier to migrate your
directory dependent
applications and servers to the
cloud. Just like with our
managed SQL server service, your
IT and security teams can focus
on higher value tasks by
spending less time on server
maintenance and security
configurations. You can keep
your user and password data on
premises using methods like one
way force level trust, while
allowing users to authenticate
against the managed service in
the cloud for lower latency and
geo availability.
Here you see
us logged into SharePoint
running in a GCEVM that is
domain joined with managed
Microsoft AD. As you can see,
the user identity still
originates from on prem active
directory. So we now have SQL
server and active directory
running as managed services on
GCP. These services work with
your familiar tools. This will
help you focus more on
delivering higher value
experiences for your customers
and employees instead of
managing and securing
infrastructure. Managed SQL
server and managed active
directory are coming to GCP
later this year.
Now, let's
take another look at what's
always on everyone's mind:
Security. To help secure your
Windows workloads, GCP provides
defense in depth. We offer
shielded VMs for Windows
analytics which are hardened by a
set of security controls that
protect Enterprise workloads
from treats like remote attacks,
privilege escalation and
malicious insiders. This is a
simple checkbox item when
creating your VMs. This is just
one example of the tools you
have at your disposal to help
secure your workloads.
We
covered a lot of topics this
morning, so let's recap. You
want to spend more time
delivering innovative products
to your customers and less time
managing infrastructure and
security. You can do this by
choosing managed services and
advanced security for your
Windows workload on GCP. Thank
you, and back to you, Thomas.
[Applause]
>> Thank you, Deepti. To talk
about their experience using
Google Cloud, please welcome
Justin Arbuckle from Scotiabank.
Justin?
>> Thank you.
>> Tell us a little about
Scotiabank. You're ten times
older than Google, a 200 year
old bank. Tell us a bit about
your business and how you have
been a market leader for so
long.
>> Well, we're Canada's most
international bank. We're in
over 50 countries, and we have a
strong retail presence in both
Canada and the Latin American
markets, which allows us to
balance the stability of the
financial services environment
in Canada as well as this
incredible innovation that we
have in the Latin American
markets. You know, over the last
few years, we have opened a
number of innovation centers,
our digital factories. And I'm
pleased to say that at the
moment, we have over 25% of all
of our global retail
transactions running off of a
digital platform that runs in
the cloud.
>> Thank you. How are you
approaching your transformation
at Scotiabank?
>> Carefully. You know, the
thing we have to realize about
transformation is that it isn't
bimodal. You can't transform
half of your organization and
not the other. And so we don't
have a bimodal transformation
strategy. We want to have a
unified digital transformation
for our entire organization. And
so for this we have to re
imagine how we build
applications for the cloud, to
be a cloud first bank. And to do
this, we've built a platform
called PLATO. And PLATO, of
course, runs on Google. And what
PLATO gives us is the ability
to be far more responsive, to be
high velocity. And I'm, again,
happy to say, that In the next
few years, we will be able to be
migrating 40% of our
applications globally to the
cloud on PLATO.
>> You know, data plays a key
role in banking. You're doing
some amazing stuff. Can you tell
the audience a little bit more
about what you're doing?
>> Yes. I mean, you spoke about
privacy before. Customers give
us their data and they trust us
with it. And trust is a critical
part. It's the core of our
business. And so looking after
that data is important, and we
take that extremely seriously.
But also, we need to be able to
use that data, the PII data and
transactional data, etc., to be
able to create complex queries
that allow us to give customers
the kind of service and
experience that they need and
want, as well as manage bank
risk. And so we are moving our
data to a global data platform
that runs on PLATO. And what
this allows us to do is be far
more responsive again to our
customer and to manage the
quality of the data that we
actually are using to make these
important decisions. But you
know, also, something that we
have to remember is that that
data, fundamentally, is the most
important asset that we have.
And so the same platform PLATO
is also providing real time data
stream of all of our
transactions globally, and what
that allows us to do is do some
really clever things with anti
money laundering, fraud, etc.
Just as a final couple of
points, I would just like to
say, if you don't mind,
Scotiabankers around the world
are wearing pink to celebrate
the International Day of Pink
which is to celebrate the fight
against homophobia, transphobia,
and all other forms of
bullying. I hope you join me.
[APPLAUSE]
And finally, I would
just like to say, I'm sure the
speakers would agree, we're up
here, we get to be up here
because of the incredible teams
that are behind us. Some of mine
are in the audience and some of
them are back home. I would
just like to say thank you.
>> Thank you very much.
[Applause]
Thank you so much.
Another part of Google's
platform that many, many
customers around the world use
is our analytics foundation.
People historically have used us
for three important reasons.
First, they want to do realtime
streaming analytics, looking at
realtime coming in realtime
streams to the cloud. Second,
they use us to augment and
enhance their Enterprise data
warehouse using BigQuery. And
third, they use us to run Hadoop
and Spark clusters without
having to run and manage them
themselves.
Today at Google
Cloud Next, we have some amazing
new capabilities in our
analytics foundation. It's
predicated on three important
things. First, to allow you to
use AI models and AutoML to
automatically categorize data
and do predictions so that a
business analyst can use AI as
part of their work. Second, we
have introduced a number of new
capabilities to make it much
easier to move data into our
cloud. Third, we've enhanced
BigQuery with even more features
and a new capability called BI
Engine to retain its
performance, scale, and
computational advantages.
We're
also grateful for a number of
partners who have worked with us
to integrate their tools and
technologies with our analytics
foundation so you can use your
favorite ETL tool, your favorite
visualization tool, your
favorite metadata management
layer. And to show you some of
these advances, please give a
warm welcome to Julie Price, a
big data specialist in Google
Cloud. Julie?
>> Thank you, Thomas. Hello,
everybody! Now, I would like for
you to think for a second about
the last time you sat at home
eagerly awaiting the delivery of
a package. Now I want you to
think about the incredible
amount of data that goes into
ensuring that millions of
packages are delivered as
expected across the globe each
and every day. Data needs to be
pulled together from so many
different places, often in
siloed systems, both internal
and external. That's what Cloud
Data Fusion is all about. It's a
fully managed and cloud native
integration service that's being
announced today. It's got a
broad library of open source
connectors    sorry open source
transformations and over 100 out
of the box connectors for all
sorts of systems and data
formats.
So let's take a look
at how data fusion shifts an
organization's focus away from
code and integrations to
insights and action. So all of
our shipping data is in an on
prem system, and we want to move
it into BigQuery so we can
further analyze it and combine
it with other date. This is
incredibly easy to do with data
fusion. Here we have defined our
on premises connection, and we
can see all of the tables that
are available. We can simply
type in to select shipment
details as that's the table that
we want to see. And so if we
click on it, we can see the data
in the table and decide what
type of transformations we want
to do.
So let's go ahead and do
a simple transformation and
delete one column. We could do
far more complex transformations
all through this UI, but we're
going to keep it very simple for
this demo. Now we
operationalize the pipeline by
clicking on create and we're
going to set it up as a batch
pipeline. Now that we've created
the pipeline, we need to define
where we want to land the data.
So if we want to load the data
into BigQuery, we just drop the
BigQuery connector as the
endpoint and connect it to our
transformation step. That's it.
That's all we have to do. And ow
we can deploy and run this
pipeline. So we've manually run
this pipeline, but of course you
can schedule your pipelines.
You can also have them
triggered. And now if we head
over to BigQuery, we can see
that we've got all of our data
loaded and ready to be analyzed
as we have deployed and run this
pipeline in advance.
Now,
you've just seen how with a few
clicks, we can create a pipeline
to move data from an on
premises system into the cloud
without writing a single line of
code. And as a quick reminder,
organizations across the globe
love using BigQuery to perform
analytics at scale. Because it's
completely serverless, folks
can focus on insights rather
than infrastructure and
operation. BigQuery also allows
enterprises to continue to use
their existing BI and
dashboarding tools like Tableau,
Looker, Click, and Google Data
Studio.
And with our shipping
data in BigQuery and ready to
go, we'd like to be able to
monitor our global operations
and make very quick decisions.
That's why today, we're
announcing the BigQuery BI
Engine. BI Engine is the native
BigQuery accelerator that
enables you to visually analyze
and interact with your data at
the speed of thought, all with
incredible scalability and
security. It's now available
through Data Studio, and we've
got other BI partners coming
soon.
So let's have a look at
our shipping data in data studio
dashboard that's powered by BI
Engine. Now, right away we can
see that there's something going
on with Brazil. It looks like
Brazil has significant delivery
delays, but packages that are
shipped from Brazil are not
necessarily responsible for as
much revenue. Now, with each and
every click on this dashboard,
we are visualizing and
processing millions of rows of
data with subsecond response
time, all thanks to BI Engine.
Now, if you're in charge of
logistics at this company,
you've got to figure out what's
going on in Brazil. So how would
you do that? Many folks would
use spreadsheets to perform this
type of analysis, but we're
talking about millions of rows
of data so that would be
impossible in any spreadsheet
environment. But not in
connected sheets. Connected
Sheets is a new feature of G
Suite that is being announced
today. It brings together the
power [Applause]
Thank you.
Connected sheets brings together
the power of BigQuery with the
familiarity of the existing
Sheets products. So let's head
over to Sheets so we can take a
look. Here we've got Sheets
connected to our shipment
dataset in BigQuery, and with
the BigQuery data in Connected
Sheets, we can take advantage of
traditional functionality, like
charts, pivot tables and
functions but across the entire
BigQuery dataset. So we've got
over 100 million records in our
data set but connected Sheets
can process billions of records.
Let that sink in for a second.
Now, what's really awesome as
well is that you will be able to
accelerate connected Sheets
with the BI Engine that we just
talked about. So let's go ahead
and look at our summary
dashboard tab. Now, what you can
see here is a number of
standard functions that are
referencing a combination of
BigQuery data and data that we
have entered into the sheets. So
you can see we're using input
of min and max distance on the
left that we've entered into
sheets to calculate averages
across data that actually exist
in our BigQuery dataset. But we
really wanted to look into
Brazil's shipping delays, so
let's move over to the country
breakout tab. Now, here we're
using standard pivot
functionality but, again, across
our entire BigQuery dataset.
We're slicing and dicing the on
time delivery percent by country
and the number of zones that
each package crossed. And it
looks like packages are getting
delayed even when they don't
leave Brazil, so there might be
something going on in the
country that we need to look
into. Now we can share this
analysis with folks in Brazil
using standard collaboration
functionality common in all G
Suite products. Our colleagues
in Brazil determined that the
delays were due to highway
construction, and a simple
update to the routing software
will take care of those
issues
So now let's take this
one step further. Since we have
the data in BigQuery, how about
we use this data to predict
which routes might be
problematic in the future so we
can make adjustments and ensure
that the packages get delivered
on time? Now, as you heard
earlier, thousands of
enterprises are already using
BigQuery to store and analyze up
to petabytes of data. Every
company wants to understand and
use machine learning but not
every company has access to ML
experts. And that's why today
we're also announcing
AutoML tables
[Applause]
AutoML tables will
enable anybody that
knows data in your organization
to automatically build and
deploy state of the art ML
models at massively increased
speed and scale. So let's jump
over to AutoML tables and take a
look. Here you can see we've
connected to our BigQuery
dataset. And on the right hand
side, you can see the full table
schema that AutoML has pulled
in. And on the left, you simply
decide which column contains the
field on which you want to
train your model. And this
becomes what gets predicted when
you feed future data in. That's
all you have to do. You don't
have to be a ML expert. We
didn't write a single line of
SQL or TensorFlow code. AutoML
tables will find the best model
for you.
So let's move over to
the predict tab. Now, to save
time for the demo, we've already
trained the model. And once the
model is trained, then you can
easily run it against new data
by configuring the input data
fields. So we're pooling the
data from BigQuery, the new data
we want to feed in, and then
you can feed the resulting
predictions back into BigQuery
for further analysis and
visualization.
So let's have a
look at that in Data Studio. Now
we can augment our BI with AI.
We can begin to enhance our
historical dashboards with
predictive insights. So this
dashboard might look pretty
familiar, but our map is now
showing predicted delivery
delays instead of historical.
And since we solved some of the
issues in Brazil with rerouting
around the construction, now we
can focus on where we expect the
next delays to come in which,
as you can see, are predicted to
be in India. Now all of this
was done with just a few clicks
and no code, allowing you to
move from raw data to
predictions in no time.
So
you've just seen some of the
amazing new additions to Google
Cloud's fully integrated and
serverless platform. Cloud Data
Fusion, BigQuery BI Engine,
Connected Sheets, and AutoML
tables will make it easier for
folks across your organization
to quickly and seamlessly turn
data into mission critical
insights. With that, thank you,
and I would like to welcome
Thomas back to the stage.
[Applause]
>> Julie showed you a logistics
example using our analytics
foundation. A real customer in
this business that all of you
know and love is United Parcel
Service. To talk about how
they're using Google Cloud to
transform their business, please
give a warm welcome to Juan
Perez, chief information officer
of UPS.
[Applause]
>> Thank you, Thomas. Thank
you. All right. Good morning,
everyone. At UPS, every day we
solve a challenge of epic
proportions. How do we
efficiently deliver 21 million
packages every single day? And
by the way, this challenge grows
even bigger during our peak
time around the holidays when we
deliver more than 32 million
packages a day. The question is
simple: What is the best, most
efficient, and most profitable
way to do it? Well, we have just
a few ways to deliver just one
route. By the way, if you're
really curious about it, the
number of possible solutions to
deliver one route at UPS is 199
digits long. But in every case,
at the end, only one route is
the best route.
We address this
challenge head on, taking our
data analytics practice to the
next level. We designed routing
software that tells the delivery
driver exactly where to go
every step of the way during 120
pick up and delivery stops in
any given day. And by the way,
it even accounts for the most
important thing of all, and that
is taking that very important
lunch break. This software saves
UPS up to $400 million a year
and it reduces our fuel
consumption by 10 million
gallons a year. That, quite
frankly, is the power of
analytics at UPS. And using
this as a foundation, we
determined that the power of our
data opened significant
opportunities to continue to
improve our operations, and most
importantly, our customer
service. Today, with support
from partners like Google Cloud,
we're creating the UPS Smart
Logistics network, a combination
of experience, expertise and
technology, powered by realtime
data that transforms our
physical assets into the world's
most integrated network. This
is not just simply when drivers
are delivering packages on the
road. It's the loading docks.
It's where we sort packages at
UPS. Everything behind the
scenes that gets that package
delivered, that one package to
your doorstep on time every day.
Data plays a key role in the
Smart Logistics Network at UPS.
Forecasting our package volume
levels is critical to running an
efficient network. Let me tell
you how we leverage BigQuery for
the most precise volume
forecasting in UPS's history. We
gather and analyze more than a
billion data points every day,
including package weight, shape,
the size of our packages, as
well as the location, the
facility capacity we have across
the network, and customer data.
Google technology allows us to
perform analytics on this
massive dataset while providing
the platform and the capability
to run Machine Learning,
different models across all this
data. The outcome for us is
really critical. The outcome of
the forecast tells us exactly
how to load our delivery
vehicles, how to maximize the
use of our assets, and how to
ramp up our network around the
holidays. Most important of all,
it helps us make more targeted
operational adjustments,
minimizing the forecast
uncertainty that comes with the
unforgiving demands of e
commerce.
The more realtime
data we can get about the state
of a package, the better
visibility we can get into
potential challenges, and
ultimately, the better we can
serve you, our customers. It
truly is a brand new day for a
smarter, more agile, and
ultimately, a more forward
looking UPS. Our future follows a
path paved by prescriptive
analytics. That's where we're
going. Which allows us to
achieve true supply chain
visibility and efficiency in
moving goods between 220
countries and territories faster
than ever imagined. We are
grateful for the opportunity to
collaborate with great partners
like Google in a way that lets
us use our joint expertise to
bolster visibility across supply
chains around the world. Thank
you again for the opportunity to
be here.
[Applause]
>> Google has invested many
years of work in AI and Machine
Learning. We have focused on
building an AI platform that
provides a very deep
understanding of a number of
fundamental kinds of data:
Voice, language, video, images,
text, translation. On top of
this platform, We have built a
number of solutions to make it
easy for our customers and
analysts around the world to
build models, one example being
AutoML, where the software
itself helps you build a model.
And finally, to speed how
companies and organizations can
use AI and ML to transform a
business, we are delivering a
number of business solutions
that can be very quickly adopted
and can change how your
organization uses AI and ML to
run its business. To explore a
number of new advances that
we're announcing today, please
welcome Rajen Sheth from our
product management organization
for AI and ML. Rajen?
>> Thank you, Thomas. So we
believe that AI will transform
every business and every
organization over the course of
the next few years. And our goal
is to empower all of you to be
able to transform along with us.
And we're seeing it happen over
and over again with big
businesses and small businesses
alike. This is a testament to
the power of AI but also
reflects our commitment to
deliver that power to everyone
in your organization, whether
they're builders or business
users or decision makers.
So
let's start with the builders.
Builders are everyone from
machine learning experts all the
way through to developers who
are just getting acquainted with
AI for the first time. And if
you're a builder, you're on the
forefront of AI. You're facing
the most complex challenges and
solving problems in a brand new
way. And we have spent years
working to understand your
needs, and we have used those
insights to build the most
sophisticated platform for AI
development anywhere.
So today
I'm delighted to announce our
Google Cloud AI platform. The AI
platform is what happens when
every step of the AI development
process meets the best of
Google. Everything from robust
end to end Machine Learning
pipelines from beta all the way
through to production, to things
like samples and tools for
everyone, hosted Jupyter
notebooks, and a hosted
environment to make deployment
and management of machine
learning easy. And importantly,
we believe that empowerment
means giving you the most
flexible hybrid cloud so you can
deploy machine learning in our
cloud, on premise, on other
clouds, and at the edge. And
this is made possible by what we
call Kuplo, an open source
framework for running AI
anywhere that Kubernetes runs
and can be managed by Anthos.
We have also added the AI Hub
which is a one stop shop for all
of your AI resources. It allows
you to use prebuilt AI
resources from a wide range of
sources and also share your own
solutions within your
organization. In addition to
that, we're committed to making
it available for more and more
developers to be able to access
AI, and as Thomas mentioned,
AutoML is really doing this.
AutoML makes it easy for you to
able to create build Machine
Learning models on your
particular dataset.
Now, when
we introduced AutoML last year,
we made it easy to do things
like image classification,
natural language processing, and
translation, and make it
accessible to everyone,
regardless of technical
expertise. AutoML is one of the
highest quality and simplest
solutions anywhere for building
custom Machine Learning models
and training them on your data.
And this year we're delighted to
introduce two new members of
the AutoML family: AutoML video
and AutoML tables, which extend
the power of AutoML to video
content and structured tabular
data. So now to demonstrate what
builders are capable of, we've
invited one of our biggest and
most ambitious cloud AI
customers to join us, so please
welcome up Binu Mathew, head of
digital products for Baker
Hughes GE.
>> Hello. I'm Binu Mathew, and
I'm the head of digital products
for Baker Hughes, a GE company.
I run a team of developers and
data scientists that work to
create advanced analytic
products to solve complex
industrial problems at a massive
scale for customers,
predominantly in the oil and gas
industry. We work with Google
Cloud for this very reason. Our
AI based solutions developed on
the Google Cloud give us the
scale and flexibility to build
our analytics models. And of
course, on the deployment side,
it gives our customers the
choice to deploy on the Google
Cloud platform. So combined with
the other Google technology we
use, such as cube flow pipelines
for managing end to end ML work
flows, Kubernetes and
TensorFlow for deep learning
capabilities, we view the Google
relationship as very strategic
in the oil and gas industry.
So
what are we trying to solve? In
the oil and gas industry, one
of the most persistent problems
we face is something called non
productive time. And essentially
this means the machine is shut
down. And that sounds simple but
it's not often for the reasons
you would think. There's a
system of machines connected to
more machines and those systems
are connected to more systems,
and the problem is usually an
interaction between these
thousands of machines. And non
productive time can mean
millions of dollars lost, if not
more.
And the way that that
has been addressed in the past
is not scalable. You've often
had an engineer modeling data in
a spreadsheet or an operator
relying on past experience
instead of realtime data. And so
Baker Hughes's cloud based AI
capabilities can now analyze
hundreds of terabytes of data
and at a level of entire systems
and continuously learn
unsupervised from normal
behavior. That significantly
increases the accuracy, scale,
and predictive power of our
models and gives us a much
better chance that system issues
that result in non productive
time can be found in advance and
circumvented entirely. Now that
also takes significant
computation, which Google Cloud
easily accommodates by fluidly
scaling across GPUs, and GPUs
are critical to AI. And for our
customers, this kind of rapidly
scaling AI means fewer machine
problems, safer operations, less
down time, and money saved.
Thank you.
[Applause]
>> Thank you, Binu. It's
amazing to see what a difference
AI can make when builders think
big. But hat if you're a
decisionmaker and what you care
about is how this can make a
difference for your key business
goals? You can benefit from AI,
too. Which is why we're
offering a growing range of AI
solutions to help solve some of
your most pressing needs.
Business decision makers can
benefit from AI with a variety
of different types of solutions,
and I want to talk to you about
three that we're introducing
today. So first we're launching
what we call document
understanding AI which helps
organizations automatically
extract insights from documents
but also make your business
processes easier. This could be
from everything like invoice
processing to identifying
content within contracts, so
many, many, many other use
cases. And so for instance,
Commerce Bank is working with
our launch partner, Iron
Mountain, to explore ways that
this can help simplify GDPR
compliance for HR.
We're also
looking at challenges faced by
specific industries, and we're
starting with retail. And for
retail customers, today we're
launching what we call
recommendations AI. And it draws
upon Google's deep experience
in personalization to deliver
product recommendations at
scale. And we have seen some
pretty amazing results so far,
with revenue on recommended
items increasing by as much as
50% for some of our first
customers.
And finally, I want
to talk to you about contact
center AI which makes it
possible to scale phone support
without compromising the
customer experience. Its virtual
agents can automatically help
callers with the most common
tasks, but in addition, its
agent assist tool can
automatically feed information,
relevant information and work
flows, to human agents for those
more complex calls. And it's
based on dialog flow which makes
it easy to build intelligent
chatbots that can answer
question and perform tasks
through natural language.
Now,
one thing that's important is we
want to make sure this
integrates into what you already
have. And so what we've done is
we've integrated this with the
top telephony providers and
contact center providers market,
so this should just insert
directly into what you have
today without rip and replace.
So to talk a little bit about
what we have, I'm excited to
welcome up Sarah Patterson,
Senior Vice President of
product, marketing and strategy
from Salesforce, and Karen Van
Kirk, VP of viewer experience
at Hulu.
[Applause]
Thank you,
Sarah and thank you, Karen, for
coming to Google Next. I want to
talk a little bit about what
you're doing. And so, Sarah, can
we start with you, and can you
tell us a little bit about
Salesforce Service Cloud?
>> Absolutely. Thanks, Rajin.
So I've been at Salesforce for a
little over ten years, and its
developers and IT leaders, like
everybody who is here today, and
everyone who is watching
online, you have really been our
lifeblood. You've actually made
Service Cloud the market leader
because you have taken our
platform and you've used it to
help your companies
differentiate their offerings
with service. Service is
becoming your brands. And now
our customers are asking us to
make it easier to deliver great
service using intelligence,
which brings us to the
partnership between Salesforce
and Google Cloud.
>> Absolutely. And we're really
excited about the work that
we're doing together and the
fact that today we're announcing
that partnership with
Salesforce Service Cloud to
build the contact center of the
future. And so can you tell us a
little bit about how you're
using Google Cloud AI
technologies?
>> Google Cloud allows us to
accomplish two powerful goals.
First, chatbots that we all know
and love. They provide a really
great way to help companies to
engage with customers and scale
your support without scaling
your costs. And we call our AI
powered chatbots Einstein bots.
We wanted to give them a fun
little name. Service cloud users
can now bring Google's dialogue
flow into Einstein bots to
augment or natural language
processing capabilities and add
in Google's extensive multi
lingual support.
We're also
excited to announce that we're
integrating Google's contact
center AI with Service cloud.
Phone, believe it or not, is
still one of the primary
channels for support. And by
combining contact center AI with
our ecosystem for telephony
partners, Service Cloud users
can now elevate their phone
support all through the
interface that they're already
familiar with.
>> That sounds great. And so,
Karen, can you give us more
about how this is making a
difference at Hulu?
>> Sure. Hulu is one of the
largest streaming services with
over 25 million subscribers in
the U.S., and we're growing
really quickly. That growth is
great, of course, but it brings
customer support challenges as
well. A big part of our solution
is our partnership with
Salesforce and 59 with
technologies like chatbots, but
even the best bot is not a
replacement for humans, so
that's why we offer phone
support as well. And we really
believe that AI is the next
logical step to bring it all
together. And that's where
Google's contact center AI comes
in. It improves the customer
experience because each call
will start with a conversation
with a virtual agent rather than
fumbling with a phone tree. And
it will make our human agents
more productive because
knowledge articles and workflows
will surface realtime based on
what is going on during the
call. And finally, we'll have
better data quality and
analytics. We can monitor
language and sentiment realtime
to flag incidents. And then we
can also dive in to better
understand what is driving
customer satisfaction.
>> These are amazing
capabilities. And so can you
give us an example of how this
helps the customer experience in
ways that you haven't been able
to do before?
>> Yeah. Customers will often
mention a show they're
interested in watching, and that
can be a great signal for the
agent to know how to work with
them; for example, suggesting a
change in their subscription
plan to better meet their needs.
So let's say a customer is
thinking about adding live TV to
their account and they happen
to mention an interest in
basketball. Agent assist can
automatically recognize the
topic and surface information to
the agent to help them have a
better conversation with that
customer, perhaps a reminder
that the NBA playoffs are about
to start. From there, agent
assist will surface personalized
recommendations and the
workflows needed to make the
change to the plan.
>> That's incredible. It seems
like a new level of customer
engagement.
>> Yes. With Service Cloud and
Contact Center AI, we'll be able
to improve that customer
experience and drive efficiency
at the same time.
>> And we're here to empower
everyone here today to build the
next generation of service
experiences.
>> Great. Thank you both for
joining us. We really appreciate
it.
[Applause]
>> Thank you.
>> So you know, for a long
time, building AI products has
seemed like bringing things from
the future which often seem
like science fiction and
bringing it to the present day.
But these stories really show
you how AI is making a
difference for customers today.
The future is now. And so let's
go make it happen together.
Thank you.
[Applause]
>> Many companies are using AI
today to transform their
businesses. When you go back
home, think about how AI and our
technology can help you change
your business. 15 years ago, 15
years and nine days to be
precise    Google launched a
product called Gmail. It was
launched with a very simple
premise: Every human should be
able to do mail from wherever
they are. All they'd need is a
browser. Today, that product is
used by over 1.5 billion people
every day. We believe, however,
we're poised for the next wave
of change in collaboration. Our
vision is very simple: Enable
collaboration for everyone in
the world, not just white color
workers but the 2.2 billion
people who are called front line
workers: Nurses, pilots,
aircraft technicians, repair
workers, all of whom now have a
digital device called a
smartphone, allowing them to
collaborate from everywhere
using the devices they have,
using all of their senses. They
should be able to speak to
people instead of having to
type, see things using the
camera instead of having to
always enter things on just
text. They should be able to
collaborate in context, and
using AI, we should be able to
augment how they collaborate. We
have an amazing new set of
capabilities in G Suite. To show
you that and explain our vision
for it, please welcome Amy
Lokey, Vice President user
experience for G Suite. Amy?
>> Hi, everyone. It is
fantastic to be here with you
all today. I lead user
experience for G Suite, and I'm
excited to talk to you today
about how we are elevated human
accomplishments and helping
businesses transform the way
they work. I love working on
these products because it's
incredibly rewarding for me and
my team to hear from our users
that we help people accomplish
their most important goals with
our cloud native collaborative
tools. G Suite is comprised of
apps that over 1.5 billion
people use, like Gmail, Docs,
Sheets, and Drive, and it
includes solutions specific to
the enterprise, like Hangouts,
Meet, and Chat. We also provide
solutions for students and
educators. And I'm excited to
show today that more than 90
million students and faculty are
using G Suite for education.
[Applause]
Today, more than 5
million businesses use G Suite.
And this includes digital
innovators like Netflix,
Spotify, and Lyft who built
their businesses with G Suite
and continue to scale with us
today. More traditional
enterprises like Verizon,
Neilsen, and Car4 who need to
adapt to a changing landscape
also turn to G Suite. Companies
with large front line mobile
workforces are increasingly
turning to G Suite. So, for
example, Air Asia uses G Suite
to connect air crews, flight
operations, and ground staff,
helping to improve their on time
performance. These customers
are turning to us because they
know that this transformation
provides tangible business
impacts.
According to a recent
Forester total economic impact
study, customers moving to G
Suite saw, on average, 1.5%
topline revenue growth as well
as efficiency improvements,
equivalent to saving each
employee one month of time.
These are just a few examples of
businesses that are re
imagining how they work.
So
let's dig in on how G Suite
empowers teams to make it fast,
make it smart, and make it
together. Here are some
examples. First, make it fast.
Teams need to be able to move
quickly, whether it's responding
to a customer request or
getting a product to market.
We've built AI into G Suite to
remove repetitive mundane work
that gets in the way. The Google
assistant can now help people
get more done at work the same
way it can at home or on the go.
I'm incredibly excited to
announce today that the
assistant will be able to access
your G Suite Calendars so you
can see what your day looks like
and stay on top of any schedule
changes. Let's try it out. Hold
on, hold on. Okay, Google,
what's next on my calendar
today?
>> Next up, you have G Suite
spotlight session today at 11:00
a.m.
>> Awesome. But I might be
running late coming from this
keynote. Okay, Google, tell the
meeting attendees to save me a
seat in the front row.
>> Here's the message to the
attendees. Do you want to send
it or change it?
>> Looks good. Let's send it.
>> Okay. Your message was sent
to the attendee.
>> Okay. How cool was that?
Time for the applause. Great!
[Applause]
Next, let's talk
about how G Suite helps teams
make it smart. With G Suite,
everybody has better access to
the knowledge and the
information and people that help
them make well informed
decisions. Two years ago, we
introduced Cloud Search which
brings the power of Google
search into your business. We
also operate as a stand alone
solution so that even businesses
who have not yet adopted G
Suite can harness the power of
Google search. Today I'm excited
to announce that we are making
third party connectivity in
Cloud search available to
eligible G Suite customers.
Cloud Search will not index data
sources like SAP, Salesforce,
and SharePoint, in addition to G
Suite, enabling employees to
search and find every digital
asset and person in the company.
Finally, G Suite helps teams
make it together. Individual
contribution is almost always
one piece of a larger puzzle
that requires multiple people to
solve. Last year, we introduced
Hangouts Chat, our messaging
platform built for teams. I'm
incredibly excited to share with
you today that we are bringing
chat into Gmail so that all of
your team communication can be
in one place.
[Applause]
Now from Gmail, you'll have the
people, the rooms, and the
threaded, rich content right at
your fingertips. Now, I've
gotten to use this for a couple
months internally, and I have to
say that it has changed how I
communicate. Everything is
easier, it's more efficient, and
I feel much more connected to
my team.
Now, as much as we
rely on chat and e mail,
sometimes the easiest way to
connect with people is just to
pick up the phone. I'm excited
to share today that Voice, the
cloud telephony service built
for G Suite, is now
generally available.
[Applause]
Thank you.
Voice gives each employee a
phone number that works from
anywhere on any device, and it's
easy for admins to manage and
provision. And with our text to
speech technology, it's easy to
set up a welcoming, interactive
menu to greet the people that
call your business.
Now, Thomas
and I have both talked a bit
about how G Suite connects
frontline workers to the back
office to accelerate access to
data and information, but what
does this look like in practice?
Let's take a look at the retail
industry. This is inspired by
how we see our customers using G
Suite today. So this is Frank.
Frank is a store manager at a
national apparel chain. He's had
three customers ask for the
same sneakers in one day, so he
realizes these shoes must be
hot, but Frank is worried his
store is losing sales because
these shoes are not in stock. So
Frank logs into a shared
Chromebook tablet from the store
floor, he jumps into chat, and
he pings a room with other store
managers to see if they're
noticing the same thing. Frank
quickly confirms the other
stores are experiencing the same
spike in demand. Well, it turns
out a YouTube celebrity
recently sported these shoes,
setting off an instant trend,
but unfortunately they don't
stock these shoes on the west
coast. With chat, Frank and his
community of store managers feel
engaged and empowered to
influence the store's strategy.
Frank and his colleagues quickly
send a heads up to corporate
using Google forms. Their input
is immediately captured and
visualized in sheets, enabling
headquarters to detect the issue
and adjust their distribution
strategy.
While retailers have a
lot of data on the products that
they stock and sell, it is hard
to gauge customer demand for a
product that's not on your shelf
which creates a blind spot.
With G Suite, Frank and his
colleagues on the store floor
can share this valuable data
that might have otherwise been
missed. Back at headquarters,
the team uses Hangouts Meet to
quickly reach a decision on how
to supply these sneakers. And as
we watch their meeting in a
moment, you will see that
features like live captioning, a
new capability that is
important for accessibility,
makes it easy for a diverse
group to participate. Let's
check it out.
>> Good morning, everyone. It
looks like customers on the west
coast are looking for a new
sneaker that we don't stock
there. Katie, are you seeing
this in your stores as well?
>> Yes. I'm definitely seeing
this across my ten stores. These
shoes are on fire.
>> I have pulled the latest
inventory data from SAP into the
sheet. Let's see if any
warehouses are overstocked where
we can pull product from.
Fortunately, looks like we have a
ton of stock in the Midwest.
I'll run the numbers and work
with our partners at UPS to get
that shipped ASAP.
>> Great. Thanks for the quick
work, everyone.
>> As you saw, artificial
intelligence in sheets means
that employees can analyze data
through a conversational query
and data can be easily pulled in
from databases like BigQuery
and SAP. Teams across the
retailer, from the store floor
to headquarters, were connected
and data moved instantly,
enabling the company to quickly
get the shoes on to the feet of
west coast customers like myself.
So in closing, I'll
leave you with this quote from
one of our customers ATB
Financial. That's pretty
incredible. After moving to
G Suite, nobody at ATB Financial
would ever go back because it's
changed who they are. G Suite is
not only a catalyst for
elevating the way that your
teams work together and
accelerating their access to
information, it's an investment
in your people and your culture.
I'm excited to see you make the
jump to G Suite, and I am
confident you will never want to
go back. Thank you.
[Applause]
>> A company that made the jump
to G Suite and has decided
never to go back is Whirlpool.
Would you all give Michael Heim,
chief information officer
Whirlpool, a warm welcome to
Google Cloud Next? Mike?
>> I'm fairly certain I just
sold a dryer backstage. So it's
clear that Google Cloud is
helping me drive that, so I
appreciate that.
>> Thank you. Mike, you're an
early enterprise customer of
G Suite. What made you decide to
join Google Cloud?
>> Well, we started our
implementation in 2014, but the
story goes back before that. We
were emerging from a general
recession in our business. We
saw tremendous innovation on our
product pipeline, and we really
had the ambition to get that
product to market faster. That
required us to change the way we
work, the way we engineered
across our global engineering
centers, and we embarked on a
mission, partnering with our
friends in HR and our colleagues
and facilities, to renovate our
buildings, change our culture,
and then put in place a new
productivity suite to underline
all of that. We called that
strategy the winning workplace,
and it was really about we put
our consumer in the center and
it was really all around how do
we live differently digitally
and then how do we work
differently digitally? So that
whole strategy really began to
drive our thinking around what
is the right platform? And we
got a little bit crazy. Not only
do we want to change consumer
experiences but we wanted to
change our business partners
experiences with us. And we
decided to conduct a series of
tech fairs. We brought in three
competing products, and we let
our business partners come in,
our colleagues, and try them,
essentially kick the tires on
these products and see which
they might like. And
overwhelmingly, they chose
G Suite.
>> What's been the effect?
>> Tremendous, I would say. The
way in which we have driven
collaboration, productivity
inside our environment, everyone
is just thrilled is the
quickest way to say that. And
maybe a couple of stories of
what people can do on these
products. We have a plant in
Mexico to build a whole
productivity visual dashboard
around plant operations on their
own in G Suite. We got
tremendous support. And if you
haven't been in these products
and you don't understand the
challenges of versions versus no
versions, you have to really
try it. So we had one of our
best supporters is the CEO's
executive assistant. She was
tired of presentations coming to
the executive committee or
going to the board, changes,
revisions how do you keep all of
those things current. And she
really drove, no, we're going to
do it one way, we're going to
do it in Google, we're going to
set that up and when you're
done, you're done. And the
beauty of these products is
there are no revisions. When
you're operating on the same
when you see an error, fix it.
When you are operating on those
platforms, when you're done,
you're done.
We also had
another example where we
acquired a company about the
same size as our European
business. We needed to integrate
them quickly. And the first
step in that integration was
first to give the team managing
the integration the tools
because that was very early in
the deployment. And then we very
quickly brought that whole
business, if you will, into our
business and made them part of
our family. And when you can
collaborate that way and share
in that fashion, you really
increase the speed at which you
can get things to market.
>> That's amazing. What else
have you got plans for, and how
else have things changed?
>> You know, we chose one of
the big reasons we chose G
Suite and Google, we believed we
would get a constant stream of
innovation. And clearly you've
seen that again this morning,
and we've benefitted from that.
So we've not plateaued. We
started our journey in '14.
We're five years in. We're still
growing. We've got tremendous
additional productivity through
your next mile program. We thank
you for that. And we see just
continuing opportunity to drive
the way in which we work and the
change that is associated with
that.
So and maybe second one
that I will just mention, this
was our first big push towards
the cloud and both for the
enterprise, for our business
partners, and for the IT
function. What we have done as a
result of that and the success
that we have experienced that
really emboldened our strategy
to go cloud first and from that
moment until now, we've got over
80% of our workloads in the
cloud, and it really all started
with the success that we drove
from G Suite.
>> Thank you so much, Michael.
It's wonderful to have you.
[Applause] .
>> So the last piece of our
portfolio, specific solutions to
enable digital transformation
in specific industries. One of
our important assets at Google
is Geo. And to show you how
companies and Enterprises are
using Geo to transform their
business, please welcome Jen
Fitzpatrick, senior Vice
President of Geo at Google.
[Applause]
>> Good morning, everybody. I'm
happy to be here to share with
you today what we've been up to
in our Geo work at Google. For
more than a decade now, we've
been mapping the world and
translating that knowledge and
understanding into meaningful
experiences for our users. We
started many years ago by
mapping roads so we could help
people reliably get from point A
to point B. But over time, what
we've seen is our users showing
an appetite for more and more
types of knowledge and
understanding about the real
world. They asked us more and
more complex questions, and they
fully expected maps to be able
to provide helpful answers or
experiences in new types of
contexts. So we sought off to
deepen our understanding of the
world, to bring new types of
knowledge and understanding to
the map as well as more dynamic
and realtime content. The real
world changes fast, and keeping
up with the pace of that change
can be a challenge. But in
recent years, advances in
technology have helped us get
smarter about the way that we
build maps. Using the power of
Machine Learning and what we
know about the world through
things like imagery and user
contributed content, we're able
to keep Google Maps fresh,
accurate and realtime for more
than a billion users all around
the world. Let's take a quick
look at how we do that. We use
Machine Learning algorithms to
look for changes in satellite
imagery which allows us to
automatically detect new roads.
Based on this approach, over the
last nine months, we have added
half a million kilometers of
new roads in more than 20
countries. With a similar
technique, we can automatically
detect and draw building
outlines, which has allowed us
to more than double the total
number of buildings on the map
around the world in less than a
year. We continue to push the
bounds of what it means to map
the world and to have an
incredibly rich and up to date
data model.
Now, what does this
have to do with all of you?
Google maps platform is the
means by which we give our
enterprise customers access to
the same rich and complex real
world information that we use to
power our consumer products.
This has long been an area of
focus for us. In fact, our
original maps APIs are well over
ten years old. What we see
happening today is a real
acceleration in businesses
finding new ways to use location
and real world insights to
transform their customer
experiences as well as how they
operate.
Let me share a few
examples. Transportation has
always been an obvious area of
focus for us given our core
emphasis on helping people
navigate the world. And as the
transportation industry
continues to transform, we're
partnering with many different
players, from automakers to ride
sharing to public transit. In
the automotive space, we've
partnered with automakers for
years to bring information from
Google maps into cars, but in
recent years, we've begun going
deeper, partnering with auto
companies like Volvo and
Mistusibhi to bring a fully
embedded voice driven, auto
tailored version of Google maps
and the Google assistant to the
car, and we're excited to see
the first cars with this new
experience hit the streets next
year.
But really, this is just
the start. Cars are quickly
becoming more connected and
gathering larger and larger
volumes of sensor data. So
whether it's making sense of
telemetry data from cars or
spotting part performance trends
or helping manage in car
machine learning and compute, we
see many ways that we can
partner together.
Ride sharing
is another industry that we
partner closely with. Today we
power more than 800 million
routes each day for customers
like Ola, DD, Go Jack, Lyft,
MyTaxi, and more. Beyond just
navigation, though, we're
helping to provide insights that
can drive realtime decisions
and optimizations for their
vehicle fleets so operations get
more efficient and riders and
drivers can have a great
experience. We're excited to
keep innovating with our
partners to unlock even more
benefits to the transportation
industry, as well as for cities
and public transit agencies all
around the world.
The
information that we know about
places, businesses on the map,
and points of interest all
around the world also bring
great opportunity for
enterprises of many types. Let
me share a few more examples.
Last year we introduced a
tailored solution for the gaming
industry, letting game studios
use the power of Google maps to
build real world games, creating
virtual game worlds based on
real life locations or creating
game play in the real world
based on the Maps' knowledge of
where the best spots to play
are.
The game studio Mixi was
an early customer and partner
for us here. And when they added
a real world experience to
their already successful game
Monster Strike, they saw a 30%
increase in daily sessions per
user. And this experience isn't
unique to gaming. As the world
has gone mobile, location based
capabilities are repeatedly
transforming customer
experiences across a wide range
of industries.
The travel
industry is another area where
knowledge of real world places
is absolutely critical to
success. And so we're working
with travel booking sites to add
our deep understanding of
places directly into their
customer experiences. Servicing
the right information about what
places are nearby when someone
is trying to make a decision can
help drive conversions and turn
casual explorers into real
customers. These are just a few
of the innovative ways we see
our customers taking advantage
of the Google maps platform.
Now, many of my examples today
have been about enterprises
using Google Maps platform to
provide better experiences for
their customers, but we're also
working with companies around
the globe to provide real world
insights that help drive
operational efficiency. From
retail to insurance to finance
and more, we're helping with
things like where to best target
your promotional spend, where
to best locate your next
storefront, and many, many more
things beyond. So no matter what
industry you're in, location
based data and insights can have
a powerful impact on your
business, and today more so than
ever. We encourage you to think
about how you can use the power
of location to transform your
business. And with that, I'll
turn it back to Thomas.
[Applause]
>> So we at Google are using
our cloud to bring the best of
all of Google's technologies to
enterprises. And one of the
industries that we've had a long
history of working with is
health care. Our mission is to
help organize different kinds of
information that health care
providers need, like electronic
medical record information,
genomic data information,
clinical trials information to
help organize it so that
providers, life sciences
companies, and others can use
that information in new ways to
take care of patients and
prevent disease. One of the
customers that we have been very
fortunate to work with is
McKesson. And please welcome
Andy Zitney, chief technology
officer of McKesson, to Google
Next. Andy?
>> Thomas.
>> Andy, thank you for coming.
We're very excited to have you
with us. Tell us a little bit
about how your IT organization
is solving your key business
problems.
>> Yeah, first of all, thanks
for allowing McKesson to be a
part of Google Next. We do
appreciate it. For McKesson,
Google Cloud is much more than
the technology, right. For us,
it's more about the culture and
what it brings to the table of
not only the IT but truly the
culture of Google to the table.
We're a 180 year old company.
We've been dealing with
suppliers, partners, customers
for 180 years. It's critical for
us to take a look at emerging
technologies and how we change
the way we do business and what
we deliver to the workforce.
It's my job to take a look at
the emerging technologies that
we can bring in for the business
and enable them to deliver at
speed. It's more important now
than ever. And if you take a
look at the technology that
Google Cloud brings, it fits
that space and allows us to
deliver at speed.
Several years
ago, McKesson started a journey
looking at what we should do
moving to the cloud. We
partnered with a people, a few
other companies and had looked
at selling some of our data
centers, getting rid of some of
the legacy equipment, and really
forcing the move to cloud
services to eliminate a lot of
the complexity that an on prem
data center gives you.
Our
existing cloud strategy was a
lift and shift. That really
wasn't getting the job done for
us. After four years, we looked
back. We didn't make the
progress that we really thought
we should have at that point in
time, so we had to look for a
new partner, and once again,
that's where Google came in and
Google Cloud. And in the
meantime, we were running
analytics projects and looking
at POCs, those two conversations
sort of came together, looking
at re inventing the
infrastructure but then the
Google Analytics platform, too.
Google, it became apparent,
really understands healthcare.
They understood our business.
They understood the regulatory
and compliance issues and
complications that it brings. It
brings customer focus to the
table. Plus, we needed to move
faster. And Google really
brought that culture of moving
with speed and engineering
mindset to the table.
>> That sounds like a strong
signal.
>> Yeah. It was really
interesting for us, right?
Google came to the table and
made us forget everything that
we knew, basically tore up and
blew up all of our processes,
challenged everything that we
did, and brought a software
engineering mindset to the table
and an automation first mindset
that really made us rethink.
Google has been around for a
long period of time now. It's
not a start up any more, but
they still have that move at
speed and move with agility
mindset. And that really made us
start to think we can do
different things. The work
approach that Google brought was
really a shift in our culture.
Google Cloud became an actual
contender for our major shift in
transformation projects. They
competed well by showing up much
differently than the others.
And it really comes back to that
culture and mindset of moving
with speed and enabling the
business through the technology.
To be honest with you, at the
beginning, I think my team was
taken aback by Google's
approach, because it wasn't just
the lift and shift. The team
seemed a little bit frustrated
from a partner coming to the
table and telling us we needed
to significantly change the way
we were delivering and think
differently. The leadership
viewed that as an opportunity to
change things significantly,
much faster than we had in the
past. We looked at it as maybe
we should be stepping back,
thinking more like a software
company, more like a software
engineering company as Google
is. It's not what we were doing
at the current point in time.
Our incumbents were telling us
lift and shift was the way to
go. Make it a cost saving
initiative. That's not the case.
Google said reinvent yourself.
Make yourself better. We sent
the engineer teams back out. We
met with our peers. We met with
Google engineers. And it became
very clear Google was winning a
lot in this space, not just
small accounts but large
enterprise accounts. Pretty
quickly, the resisters that were
in the teams sort of gave in,
saw what we could do for the
company and really how much IT
could shift from being a back
office function to a
differentiator for the business.
My director of strategy,
Trevor, always says, you know,
we want to shift IT from being
the people that just maintain
technology to being people and a
team that is driving
differentiation to the business
and enabling them to deliver
product at speed. That means the
move to the cloud for us and a
cloud architecture needs to be
put in place so that we can
deploy features faster,
continuous deployment,
continuous testing, and deliver
and fix security across the
board in a seamless manner,
right. Enabling that speed once
again. This moves us from below
the line, low value added
services in IT, to above that
line and delivering value to our
business and not just business
as usual.
>> That's a great outcome.
Thank you so much for your
partnership, and thank you for
coming to Google Next.
>> Appreciate it.
Thanks for having us.
[Applause]
If you're a media
company or telecommunications
company, Google can help you
with audience acquisition, media
asset management, media
archiving, streaming
infrastructure, and the ability
to reach consumers directly. Not
only have we built technology
for the industry, we're also
very proud to announce today a
partnership with Accenture,
announcing an intelligent
customer engagement solution for
a number of industries using
Google's platform. Let's hear
from the Paul Doherty, chief
technology officer of Accenture.
[Applause]
>> I think the ultimate power
of the Google Cloud platform is
the acceleration of innovation
that you get. Digital
transformation is the big thing
that's happening in companies
with right now. Energy,
utilities, travel, financial
services, insurance,
communications, media,
technology, all have some of
these common needs that we think
we can solve together. Every
exchange you have with a
customer needs to improve trust,
and all it takes is one bad
interaction to destroy trust.
That's where the
Accenture/Google Cloud
partnership comes into play,
bringing together industry
expertise and solution
capability of a company like
Accenture with a powerful
technology platform with Google
and accelerating customer
solutions and bringing a new
platform innovation to customers
who are looking to draw up
their business faster.
>> Please welcome David Klein,
chief technology officer of
Viacom, a media company working
so closely with us. David?
[Applause]
David, welcome.
Thank you for coming.
>> Thank you.
>> Viacom is delivering an
incredible number of
entertainment experiences,
billions of people every day.
How are you using Google Cloud
to make that possible?
>> So Viacom creates and
distributes iconic content
across the globe, Paramount
Pictures, Nickelodeon, MTV, BET,
Comedy Central, AwesomenessTV
through Viacom Digital Studios,
Pluto TV, which is a new
acquisition, experiences like
the BET Experience, live events,
KCAs, Kids Choice Awards, and
then what we do on the daily
events, The Trevor Noah Show,
The Daily Show, what we do for
things like Paw Patrol and
animation. So all of that leads
up to a great user experience
and iconic memories. With that
said, Google Cloud very much
enables us to look at a whole
bunch of fine points, security,
reliability, scalability,
enabling us to take that content
and enrich it, ML/AI, and how
do we at the end of the day,
enable the consume experience to
be awesome by being on your
cloud.
>> Why were we the right
partner for you?
>> So that starts with
partnership, just in the words
you said. I will tell you, to
begin with, your sales group,
your engineers, your dev ops
teams, your ML and AI teams were
very much broad in knowledge
bust also came in with the
understanding of really wanted
to understand what Viacom needs.
What's our strategy? What do we
looking to accomplish? How are
we looking to accomplish that?
And then how can the Google
tools sit on top of us and make
sure that we're enabling and
growing with it.
So what I would
say to begin with,
understanding our culture.
Viacom's got a very rich and
traditional culture that is
based on creativity. And that
creativity was enabled by Google
coming in and really taking
some time and thinking about
what can we do with you? What
can we do with things in the
music industry? What can we do
around girls who code, which I'm
a big advocate of, with women
in engineering and what goes on
in the space of an inequality of
dev ops and how we help balance
that. And then really then came
in and helped us understand
some of the things you've done
around search, around metadata,
around enhancing that content,
and really coming together on a
joint opportunity on how we can
take our content and really
enrich it, as I mentioned
earlier. That's our intellectual
property. Taking that content,
putting it up in the Cloud,
making it accessible, knowing
that it's safe. Knowing that
it's got the proper if you want
to call it ability to enhance
and entice our consumers is a
big piece. And we really have
just gotten started on the
journey, but we are so very
excited and very much looking
forward to a future.
>> Thank you very much for
coming and thank you for your
partnership.
>> Thank you. It's a pleasure!
[Applause]
>> Lastly, retail. An industry
where Google helps so many
organizations. We've introduced a
number of new products targeted
for retail, developed these
search products using images,
recommendations, e commerce
hosting, ordering things online
with a digital shopping
assistant, demand forecasting,
and others. We've also built
retail health care and financial
services solutions specifically
with Deloitte. And let's hear
from chief executive officer of
Deloitte. Janet Foutty.
>> What I hear from customers
about the Deloitte and Google
cloud alliance is that they love
the richness of the Google
technology. The very, very deep
industry and domain expertise
that Deloitte brings to bear,
our focus on the end customer,
and, frankly, our ability to
execute and execute
aggressively. Financial
services, health care,
government, and retail are the
places where we believe we can
collectively have the most short
term impact, centered in and
around where SAP is going as a
critical dimension, where
customer and marketing analytics
are going is a critical
dimension, and then all things
that surround those domains. The
Deloitte and Google Cloud
alliance allows us to address
both the great optimism and
enthusiasm about the market, as
well as the anxiety and worry
about can we keep pace with
what's to come. And it's those
fundamental that's really what
it's all about.
>> A customer in the retail
industry that's working with us
to deliver analytics and insight
in new ways is Proctor &
Gamble. Please welcome Guy
Perry, chief data and analytics
officer of Proctor & Gamble.
Guy?
Welcome. What business
problems is Google Cloud helping
Proctor & Gamble with?
>> At Proctor & Gamble, our
products touch the lives of
billions of consumers around the
world every day. Brands that
many of you know of, Tide,
Swiffer, Pantene, Gillette, all
those brands, at their core,
require data analytics as part
of our digital transformation
journey. We were looking at
digital transformation as a way
to get data as a way to disrupt
our business and better improve
the lives of consumers.
Now, to
power an enterprise like
Proctor & Gamble, there are a
lot of data signals that we're
looking to integrate and
harmonize, including purchase
information, supply chain,
consumer data on the media,
social media channels, as well
as demographics and weather.
There's more data out there from
more sources than you and I
ever would have imagined when we
first started our careers. It's
very exciting but also a great
challenge to scale for an
enterprise of our size.
Last
year, we were looking for an
agile leading edge platform on
which to collect, organize, and
analyze data. What we really
were looking for is a deep
technical capability to scale to
our needs, and so we leveraged
our experts to do an analysis of
all the cloud providers
including Google Cloud. P & G
has a very thoughtful cloud
strategy, and based on the
successful technical pilot,
we're excited to have GCP as one
of our strategic cloud
partners.
>> Why did you chose GCP?
What were  some of the
reasons you chose us?
>> So at P&G we have a very
deliberate data strategy, and we
want reliable granular data to
be integrated and harmonized and
powered by algorithms to inform
and democratize the data for
decision makers around the world
and in some cases in realtime.
So what this means is we need to
have data loading and prep at
scale and data warehouses built
and priced to handle the scale
and the future data loads that
we need to process by including
very low hassle management and
overhead. We also want to apply
the best ML and AI on top of the
data to deliver what we call
our superiority strategy, which
is irresistible superior product
and package, brand
communication, in store
execution, everything aimed at
delivering value to our
consumers and customers. So
while we're in the early days of
our GCP relationships, we found
that in the Google Cloud.
And
one last thing, the core of what
P & G stands for is passion for
consumer understanding and
focus. And even in IT, we're
looking for providers who
understand that about us and are
wanting to work with us on
those terms, and we found that
in the Google Cloud, too. So,
we're looking forward to sharing
many successes together, Thomas.
>> Thank you very much, Guy.
Thanks so much.
>> Thanks for having me.
[Applause]
>> Thanks. So, what an amazing
two days. So many product
announcements. To bring you this
technology, we at Google are
committed to expanding our go to
market teams, our work with
partners, and deepening our
industry and product focus. You
will hear a lot more from us at
events throughout the year.
Today, I wanted to thank you
all, our customers and partners,
for the amazing time you have
given us at Google and supporting
you in our vision for transformation.